when i was first thinking about
transitioning i was concerned that i
wasn't going to be able to compete what
will fans and spectators say what will
be like in the locker room trans
athletes have to think about all of that
as well as will i even be able to play
the sports that i love because of the
policies that are in place my name is
chris moser and i'm the first
transgender man to make a men's us
national team
my sport is sprint duathlon and duathlon
is run bike run when i first started
competing after transition no one really
thought that i would do well everyone
pretty much just wrote me off because
they looked at me and thought oh he's a
trans guy there's no way that he can
compete against men
hearing people say that really motivated
me to work harder to learn more to be
more dedicated to my training and try to
be the strongest competitor that i could
be
competing on team usa is a dream come
true for me
although i'm on team usa i will not be
able to compete in the world
championships in june with the policies
that are in place right now
at the world level
they follow the international olympic
committee policies and those policies
say trans athlete needs to go through a
full medical transition and they define
that as full lower surgery so including
internal and external genital
reassignment adding an extra body part
is not going to make me a faster runner
or a stronger cyclist every single day
i'm thinking about being on the starting
line and i really think that it's going
to happen i really believe that we can
get policy changed and that i will line
up with my teammates in the red white
and blue uniform and represent my
country
every day i read a quote that says be
who you needed when you were younger
that puts me in the mindset of sharing
my story and making sure that people see
me as a visibly out trans athlete
competing at a high level so that they
know that they can do that too